[Music]
so
we have discovered among the ramsey
tribe the ramsey listeners out there
that about half of you when it comes to
tax time
have a very simple return and you should
not
pay two or three hundred dollars to an
elp
a tax elp to have your taxes prepared
you should
pay someone that or more if you have a
complicated return because you're going
to make that back
now i have a very complicated return and
so i pay a lot more than that
but it makes me money back every year
because i've got a guy looking over my
shoulders and i don't know anything
about taxes i know a little bit but just
enough to be dangerous and that's a good
way to lose it but if you're just
following a simple
return to get your refund the electronic
file
is the best way to do it it really is
dave and unfortunately out there you can
get overcharged
and up sold and here's what i mean if
you end up owing money
you've got companies that'll come after
you trying to get sell you a credit card
trying to give you a loan
trying to hit you with all these things
and that's how they make their money
and it's actually really kind of a
bounty on your head
so i love what we've got this year uh
we've got a top notch
we got a choice you have a choice
basically turbo tax is about
70 of the e-file market
is it really yeah they own uh tens of
millions of people use turbo tax to file
and um you know in in general the thing
operates very well
it operates very well but as you dig
into intuit and what they're doing with
turbo tax they just paid eight billion
dollars to buy credit karma
and uh and they're pairing that together
with turbo tax so
basically they're using turbotax uh not
as a product line
but as a a funnel to get you into their
system because they want to sell you
debt
yes and they literally in their own
corporate presentation said we put a
bounty
on the when the customer pay signs up
for a credit card we get a bounty
now you know what a bounty is oh yes i
do that's when you get cat that's when
you capture or kill
a person or an animal and get paid and
you get for that coyote hide
yeah you get a bounty so if you want to
put your hide on the block
no no thank you no thank you
yeah that's what's going on and that's
that's the way these companies look at
it and so
you just you know again the actual
product itself there's nothing wrong
with it the company's not evil they're
just
they're just in the business not of
taxes they're in the business of selling
you debt well and that's the difference
between them and us
at ramsey solutions our goal is to help
you with money to help you be able to
build wealth
and so what we want to do is invite you
to come over check out ramsey smart tax
uh the other guys charge it's half of
what other guys charge
uh you can file your taxes for 17 that's
going to beat the others guys prices
hands down
and then if you need a little support
you can upgrade to the premium version
for 37
and get live access right where you are
which is amazing
uh so and if you've got a complicated
return you go to one of our elps
definitely have a full-on review
complete return
that's right done that way but if you've
got a simple return 17
is the way to go now ramsey smart tax is
brand new this year
it's brand new we put it out just for
beta testing and everything last year
and ran about 5 000 folks through it
uh but this year we'll have millions in
it and it's powered by a tax slayer this
accompanied a
family-owned company down uh augusta
georgia yes and uh we appear
but we've been working with them for a
year and a half they're wonderful people
the product
it looks acts and feels like ramsay
because it is
but the guts they down under the hood is
those guys yeah and they've got 50 years
of experience so you got two ways to do
your taxes that we would recommend
and uh and it's where i will send all of
my friends
and it's not to jump into the hoop and
get you know set up for a bounty on your
head
okay but it's go to smart tax
yeah and that's the 17 file or an
upgraded file for
35 but there's not a bunch of add-ons
there's not a bunch of gotchas there's
not a
we don't have another agenda just gonna
help you get your taxes filed it's real
simple that's right real simple real
clean
and i know it's kind of a hassle if
you've used one of the other people like
h r and their software is the same as
turbo
they're trying to set you know look at
what they're really doing yeah they're
big on the refund loans
and those refund loans are dad gun
payday lenders yes they are i mean the
the rate on these refund loans is
ridiculous
it is so be careful if your han
if you've been if you've been playing
with snakes you're going to get bet and
you could get away from them
it takes a little trouble the first year
to move it all over to something else i
know that
yeah but it's only 17 that's right and
do the trouble once and
and nobody's gonna put a bounty on you
that's right and dave and you don't get
hit with unnecessary emails
those mailers the phone calls again
there's no reason to be in that
environment get in an environment that's
trusted and protected
ramsey smart tax will help you get it
done yeah
and so here's what we do it's real
simple you're either going to go with an
elp
and have a complicated return filed and
do it properly
or you're going to use a simple ramsey
smart tax
software 17 you really can't beat this
text the word tax to 33789
and we're going to hook you up with the
help you need that's tax
to 33789 and i will make you a solemn
promise
not a single soul will ask you to take
out a credit card as a result of doing
it guaranteed guaranteed
yes not a single soul
there's not a chance you know it's
interesting so many
companies have discovered how wealthy
they can become how much money they can
make off of the consumer
if they go in the debt business the
credit card business
and so it's not unusual to look at one
of these retailers pre-pandemic
and say why does target have the target
card
why does whoever macy's have a macy's
card why do they have a store card
why does best buy have a best buy card
because at the end of the day
they make more money on the credit
and the issuing of debt 90 days same as
cash that's right
they make more money on the debt than
they do on the actual sale
of the clothing that's right or the
television or the whatever
and so you know all of these retail
operations are
a credit card operation with some stuff
out front i mean victoria's secret
you pay you know you think they're in
the business of selling tiny underwear
they're really not they're really in the
business of credit they make more if you
work at victoria's secret and you do not
put out a certain number of credit cards
every shift
they don't care how many thongs you sold
they want to know how many credit cards
you put out
because they make their money on the
credit cards
oh dave that was one of the things that
ended up chasing me out of the banking
industry
because it was one of those it was all
about the ancillary things that you
added on
to that and so they kept track of the
number of credit cards each day
that day and uh if your branch wasn't on
the list it was an issue yeah
they know what business they're in
because they know where the money is
that's right
and so you know it's you know yeah we've
got all this stuff out front you can
have a savings account a checking
account
or you can you know you can buy your
underwear here or you can get you a suit
of clothes over here
you can get your television over here
but really if you if you peel back their
financials
they make more money on the sale of debt
than they do on the other stuff and
turbo tax is exactly the same way yep
but uh i could here's the thing about
ramsay it it's uh
you may not like it you may not want to
do it 17 may sound like a lot of money
to you i don't know
but 100 of the time you are not going to
get offered a debt product as a result
of using one of our products
so we we don't put bounties on the heads
of our customers they're not coyotes i
cannot believe they use
that name that word bounty corporately
like that
that's unbelievable so that's scary
don't go there
uh you can do it a better way bonus i
could have come up with a lot of other
words yeah but
bounty feel like a coyote
bounty hunter you guys all howl out
there
you got a bounty on your head
you feel like a beaver pelt come on step
it up
come on man you feel like a rabbit
a little scared rabbit no thank you
basically a rabbit
poor turbo tax yeah they actually have a
good product but they just got
sidetracked with trying to screw you
guys with that
and it just messed them up and so along
comes lilo ramsey and
we won't have 40 million people use
ramsey smart tax this year like they did
we know
that but if we can save just a few of
you from a bounty
that's a good thing that is a good thing
[Laughter]
the things you learn on the dave ramsey
show text
tax to three three seven eight nine and
you can learn about ramsey smart tax or
our tax elps
tax two three three seven eight nine